nous allons maintenant
consulter sur
les amendements
à partir de l'avendement 2715
consultation aura lieu à main levée pour
lequel la commission a donné à naviguer
favorable et le gouvernement défavorable
d'un monde l'amendement 2715
monsieur luret
pardon
quel est votre article nous sommes en
pleine procédure de
vous pouvez inventer un numéro mais
bon monsieur Lurel s'il vous plaît
oui oui oui bon
il s'agit pas d'une loup faut crie c'est
bien alors c'est 32 alinéa E4 que le
sida vous monsieur le Président vous
incarnez le Sénat vous pouvez décider
puisque il y a un silence et entretenu
enfin que ils ont des secrets à se
partager le vrai notre règle à minuit
n'aurait peut-être pas eu à faire cette
intervention s'il avait été mis dans les
secrets que le Sénat peut se réunir d'un
comité secret que 35 sénateurs ou le
Gouvernement peut demander à se réunir
en comité secret voilà je vous demande
de mettre au voie que ton sexe sénateur
puisse demander à nos collègues et je
fais ça au nom et pour le compte de mes
collègues
libéraux enfin disons de doigts voilà
monsieur le sénateur puisque je suis
l'incarnation je rappelle que le comité
secret se tient pendant les périodes de
guerre et je pense que ça n'est pas
encore la situation de notre pays je
vous demande
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président s'il vous permettez avec sur
le temps de l'humour vous le savez nous
sommes en guerre sociale j'estime ce
l'équivalent moral d'une guerre
mais oui mais oui et donc nous demandons
le comité secret il y a pas de débat
dans ce cas là alors nous passons au
vote amendement 2715
[Musique]